I get those every
[Music]
What is up, guys? In today's video, we
are going to be using my friend's
account again. He's going to be doing
this for me. THC Butter, where's he
at? THC Butter, right there. So, huge
shout out to him again. He made the Zoro
video for us. So, he's going to go ahead
and make this video, too. So, let's get
started into the video. So, if you guys
have not read the description, for some
reason, this video is going to be loot
from an hour of bursting dust devils,
which require I think 65 slayer. So,
this is the account we are using, THC
Butter. He's a level 111. These are his
stats. He is 82 attack, 99 strength, 75
defense, 99 range, 77 prayer, 98 magic,
and 97 hit points. So, he is an almost
max 75 defense account. This is his gear
setup. a slayer helm, an oult neck, a
saridomomen mage cape, a prayer scroll,
the book of darkness, aram robe top,
aram robe bottom, ancient staff,
tormented bracelet, eternal boots, and a
sears ring in be. And lastly, his
inventory, four prayer pots, four and
some adamant darts. And the adamant
darts will be used, and I will explain
why they're in his inventory. And then
his rune pouch for the ice bursts. So,
real quickly, in order to get there, you
are in Karen by the bank. You go down
the hole, run past the giant sand crabs,
and run over there. And then you're at
the dust devils and you are good to go.
In order to bank after each inventory,
you just run up the same ladder and bank
and continue. Now we will get started
into his hour. So notice how he uses his
adamant darts on the smoke devils and
his praying melee. And he gets them into
the corner and then runs back and forth.
And this is to cause them to stack. So
that is what the darts are used for to
get all their attention and get them on
him. And then he stacks them in the
corner and he starts maging them with
the
burst. And this is what it looks like.
[Music]
All right, so there's just under 2
minutes left. We'll go ahead and bust
out this last two minutes and I will
speed up the clips so you guys can see
him finish it and then we will go to the
Grand Exchange and we will price check
everything.
[Music]
Hey, hey,
hey. All right, the hour is up. Now, it
is time to go to the Grand Exchange and
price check the loot to see how much
money we made in 1 hour. Okay, so it is
now time to check how much money we
made. Drum roll, please.
764K. Almost 765K. Now we will go to the
Grand Exchange and sell it
[Music]
all. Okay, so everything sold. Let's do
a grand total. So, we made
753,800, we got an ancient shard and two
dark totem pieces. So, that's very nice.
Now, let's do some math. So, before
doing the hour of dust devils, he
started with
11,821,771 magic experience. And he
ended with
11,933,93. So, that's 112,000 magic
experience. So, you can get about
110,000 to 120k and XP an hour. The
money he spent on supplies was 130k, 896
on chaos runes,
334,260 on death runes, 12,380 on water
runes, and 12 prayer potions, four doses
for 134,040. And so a grand total, he
spent
611,576 on supplies. And we made
753,800. That means we made a profit of
142,224 GP and we got 112,000 magic
experience. So overall, doing an hour of
dust devils is very worth it as you can
profit while doing magic. So I highly
recommend that you do this. And again,
huge shout out to THC Butter for making
this video. I hope you guys like this
video. And if you have any suggestions
for other videos, go ahead and leave it
in the comment section below. Thanks for
watching, guys. Stay tuned for my next
video.